unser fritz outlet und dann heißt
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
max heute mit am start heute in diesem
video leute machen wir eine tour durch
deutschland und zwar durch die
lustigsten ortsnamen die dieses land
jemals gesehen hat mag es auch nicht
werden voraussetzungen werden darauf
reagieren und gucken was der krasseste
ort zusammen in ganz deutschland ist
okay okay dann würde ich sagen macht mal
die augen zu werde ich den ersten jahr
aussuche korrekt ich sags mal so dicker
du im wahrsten schon mal alleine wenn
man das mal sehen möchte ohne vielleicht
mehr allzuweit eindruck zu machen kann
ich hier auf jeden fall da klein amerika
da hast du einfach so ein komplettes
miniaturmodell von amerika komplett
nordamerika südamerika einfach auch so
eine stadt von 1 2 kilometern abgebildet
perfekt perfekt ich glaube ganz ehrlich
es hat sich einfach irgendeiner gedacht
weißt was wir sind eh am arsch der welt
egal wir sind im landkreis wietzendorf
ich bin der bürgermeister von dem dorf
hier kompetenz aus scheiß einfach klein
amerika nach augen aufzumachen
ohne wissenschaftliche die aus dem
auspuff kommt selbst sagt ja ich komme
aus feldkirchen ohne wird so was kann
passieren dass irgendein bürgermeister
sich besorgten gedacht hat weiss was.de
gar wenn er nicht dass jetzt ein
fachbuch sind haben wir eigentlich die
allergrößte frage ist leute was machen
längst nicht klar dass er vermutlich
wieder den anregenden
anwaltlich beraten
man schießt dann wird man halt mal ist
aber so die stadt mit so einem
geisteskranken psyche ist und jeder
vierte da gibts noch zufrieden sein
konnten man muss meinen kopf wenn die
stadt die deutschen gefährlich am besten
ohne witz safe call gibt es unter
deutschen bürgermeistern wettstreit wer
sich den dümmsten statt namen ausdenken
kann ja das war ja das hoffe er ruft
dieser strafe ahndete damit ziehst du
halt die leute andere wäre in köln
wurden was das für name der garten sind
berlin münchen
zum namen kannst du einfach nicht auf
die straße gehen wenn ich eine frage
kommst du her aber wieder auskotzen
kommst übrigens sie haben krieg mit der
stadt pusten
nicht weg das wahlalter oder witzig will
den speck politik ich glaube da gibt es
den ein oder anderen gewalttäter in dem
ort ganzes land nein geht man das klären
lässt laufen ganz ehrlich die straße was
klären
also ich weiss nicht leute ich will
nicht reden ich will niemanden des
respektes aus diesen städten kommt aber
wenn ihr eine familie hättet oder so
oder ein unternehmen wird die wollen
dass euer unternehmen in pingsdorf
sitzen und katzenbach kosten machen
einen kurzen dorf ja das ist ein fucking
ortsschild von kissen okay dann orten
dem du wohnst heißt wissen da kann nicht
mal deine eigene oma daran vorbeifahren
und als ihr nach zu machen wie kann man
in bonn pisten wohl unsicher wie dreck
zu fühlen aber in kisten wollen
die pinkler nächste eigenen ich weiß
nicht mal kennst du das wieder mit der
bahn durch deutschland fährt und du
siehst also links und rechts orte
vorbeiziehen und längst ja krass ich
würde gern wissen daher den orten lebt
und nicht also ist nicht dann kann ich
meine geschichte die ich erzähle kleine
rote aber angenommen ist wer so fragst
du dich nicht auch gerade wer zur hölle
zum absoluten oberweg wohnt in
kloschwitz darf eigentlich dann immer
unsere fritz aus unser fritz komponiert
von sich sagt ich wohne in max was
würdest du sagen was ist dein lieblings
ortsname unser fritz ich muss sagen ihr
hellenthal auf jeden fall auch sehr
gefeiert
ich bleibe aber will man bei stecken das
was für uns heute ich hab über max kommt
euch jetzt mal in folge was das geht
verlinkt da haben wir eine folge rund um
podcast gemacht können gerne abchecken
ich bin damit dabei und